Leute ihr lauft alle in die falsche
Richtung zur Arbeit geht's da lang die
Richtung
Streik der Kanalarbeiter in Berlin ist
ja unterirdisch die brauchen einfach
mehr Bock auf Arbeit das hat auch
Steffen Camp Peter gesagt vom
Arbeitgeberverband
der Arbeitgeber fordert ja in der
aktuellen Tarifrunde 10,5 % mehr Bock
wie viel Box sind sie maximal
bereitzugeben wir können schon sagen wir
bewegen was für die Stadt und jetzt
gerade bewegen sie nix sie arbeiten ja
nicht ja wenn Sie 100% Bock auf Arbeit
hätten dann würden sie ja jetzt arbeiten
das ist ja mal klar sie arbeiten jetzt
ja nicht ja oder ja dafür
ist oder nicht immer recht sie tragen
gelb das finde ich gut die Farbe der FDP
Bekenntnis zum Neoliberalismus toll
schönes Zeichen
wie viel sind sie denn bereit in der
Woche zu arbeiten
39 40 39 irgendwie müssen wir einmal und
verhandeln ja das ist ja keine
Verhandlungsbasis
ja aber ich fahren immer noch 39 okay 39
und ich kriege die Brezel
das ist aber auch wirklich schwierig
hier
irgendwie habe ich das Gefühl hier
herrscht noch nicht die richtige
Workbook Balance dann trete ich mal als
Vermittler in Erscheinung
sie sind ja Kanalarbeiter wir sind ja
Kollegen ne ja ich bin vom ZDF vom
zweiten Kanal
[Musik]
ich wollte die Stimmung mal ein bisschen
auf lockern ja gut funktioniert
jetzt also hier wird humortechnisch wird
auch gestreikt kann man sagen
na dann verhandle ich doch mal lieber
mit den richtig wichtigen Martin urban
dem zuständigen Arbeitgebervertreter der
sieht eigentlich so aus aber heute äh
ist der offenbar inkognito hier
wir sind der Obermann richtig könnte man
die Arbeitnehmer hier vielleicht ein
bisschen besser motivieren indem man in
den gleichen Stundenlohn zahlt wie ihnen
ich werde auch nicht nach Stunden und
bezahlt aber ist ein bisschen schwierig
also wir haben das ist ja jetzt kommt
tatsächlich mein ernsthafter Satz ich
weiß mit wem rede ich denn überhaupt mit
dem Journalisten vom ZDF vom ZDF für
viele bestimmte Sendung oder so cool ich
finde auch immer gern streiken ich bin
Journalist ich würde gerne streiten
wissen was passiert wenn ich streite
ja die freien können Strände rbb
streiken die freien hier permanentenform
Bernd ja ich sage irgendwas dann
passiert dann dreht Fabian Köster den
Beitrag
Fabian wer Fabian Köster
so ein kleiner der Junge Lutz vanaust
okay
Journalist im ZDF eigentlich der
also ist mir nicht geläufig aber ich
muss auch sagen mein Gesicht ist
natürlich die Abfallwirtschaft ne ja gut
aber Abfallwirtschaft nur
egal
vielen lieben Dank bitteschön und damit
zurück ins Studio
[Gelächter]
hallo leute wenn ihr jetzt auf Gefällt
mir drückt und den Kanal abonniert zeige
ich euch meinen lautesten Schrei für das
menschliche Gehör ist der zwar nicht
wahrzunehmen aber ich würde eure Hunde
kurz rausbringen okay fertig